this week I got a rare inside look at a
pack the American Israel Public Affairs
Committee it's one of the most powerful
lobbying groups in the US and one that
impacts our elected officials decisions
on foreign policy in the Middle East and
even where our tax dollars go I attended
their annual conference which drew
18,000 supporters and every major
presidential candidate except for Bernie
Sanders
I got to hear pro-israel messaging that
was so strong facts didn't even seem to
matter we don't consider it on the
glimpse I got of the AIPAC machine in
action was as fascinating as it was
frightening here's why first the
pandering of our presidential candidates
was so intense you think they were
running for office in Israel America
can't ever be neutral when it comes to
Israel's security or survival America
will stand unapologetically with the
nation of Israel I have a newcomer to
politics but not to back to the Jewish
mistake even though he previously said
he would be neutral on the question of
Israel and Palestine truck totally
flipped the script at AIPAC and
basically regurgitated their talking
points and he even prepared a speech for
once when I become president the days of
treating Israel like a second-class
citizen will end on day one nothing
quite got standing ovations at AIPAC
like slamming the Iran deal this is a
deal that AIPAC lobbied hard against and
spent millions trying to defeat yet
failed
when questioned outside the conference
AIPAC supporters said things like this
at the end of the day the deal did pass
but inside it was a different story on
the first day in office I will rip this
catastrophic Iranian nuclear deal to
shreds
another popular way to rally the crowd
was by dehumanizing Palestinians and
blaming them for the absence of peace
Palestinian children raised in a culture
that glorifies martyrdom and the
willingness to die in the pursuit of
killing or maiming Israelis what I
didn't hear was basic context like the
fact that Israel has kept more than 4
million Palestinians under a military
occupation for decades or that Israel
continues expanding settlements on
Palestinian land in violation of
international law and long-standing US
policy those realities weren't
criticized as major impediments to peace
at all attendees kept saying they
supported peace between Israelis and
Palestinians but strangely weren't
really ready to talk about Israel's
actions in the region lastly a pax
three-day conference ended with a
massive lobbying effort literally
hundreds of Americans were bused to
Capitol Hill to urge their elected
officials to keep supporting Israel our
purpose is to talk about
it's your communities they have
even high schoolers were assigned a pack
talking points they pack like it's three
goals so personally I'm talking on the
first topic which is about like Iranian
Iranian Iranian aggressions
a pax message to US politicians is
simple support Israel and will support
you and like other strong lobbies
they're effective the u.s. gives Israel
more than three billion dollars of
military aid each year which Israel uses
to advance its interests even when they
contradict our own but seeing the lobby
and action firsthand left me asking is
this how American democracy should work